hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video wahrscheinlich zum titel
eingeblendet was wir heute machen und
zwar machen wir das größte stück der
welt
max ist mit dabei
dafür setzt wird erfand
für das größte pizza schritt der welt
haben wir uns geholt einmal und pizza
kit aber dass ich noch einmal sondern
zweimal das ist ein placement für
knacken
da die haben hier dritten was eigentlich
drin da ich salami drin was man benötigt
ein ordentliches salami benötigt hier
drin ist quasi eine pizza teigrolle und
pesto also tomatensoße und das haben wir
zwei mal geholt dann haben wir uns noch
zweimal mozzarella geholt und daraus
neue zu schneiden und den drauf zu
packen und zu hören wir noch thunfisch
völlig markt ohne socken hat man
verschenkt voll gemütlich
wieso begrüßten 14 stücken nicht die
größte pizza wir haben uns gedacht die
größte pizza da gibt es locker so viele
aber wir machen einfach nur ein stück
und nehmen dafür wickelt komplette
backblech zunächst einmal packen wir
alles aus das heißt wir nehmen hier die
ganze sache raus was geredet wird ist
das ist schon mega viel teig für eine
ganze wissen wie soll ich das nicht ich
habe zwei davon liegen jetzt drei wochen
so ein roller glaube ich respektiere ich
muss ihnen die platz kriegen ohne
sprache aber ich habe keine rolle viele
fragen sich wahrscheinlich weil so dass
diese studie dass die krasseste hiervon
wird so das riesige kaugummi und solche
videos was macht man eigentlich mit den
essensresten wir beiden wenn es essen ja
also wir haben hunger und deswegen
musste petzschner mehr weiß was ich
mache ich leg das jetzt einfach so hin
das ist quasi so die grundlage ich hab
keinen strom
ledige ich merke wie ich zu langsam
hinkriege das zu einem dreieck zu machen
aber ich werde zu machen dass ich glaube
ich das hier als grundlage genutzt und
das dann hier draußen rum bauern quasi
so ein bisschen
kino.to ist was gerade alles kaputt
gemacht
wirklich viel luft ist bis heute der das
ist nicht so normaler zeigen wie man
sich das vorstellt ein paar schicke in
den später haben wir getan
positiv was kannst du eigentlich
funktioniert sehr gut
beide leben am limit was steht da drauf
auf dem ding
das ist schon richtig es muss möglich
sein ich habe jetzt hier dieses ding
vertraulich mit einer flasche darüber
vielleicht doch an dem an dem papier
dass wir das nicht hinkriegen sitze
verkauf einem mit backpapier ausgelegten
blechen ausrollen
ja was genau wollen wir lassen das jetzt
erstmal da auf dem tisch liegen und
probiert jetzt mal hier mit der anderen
räume sind wir auf den anfang gemacht
hast
and so i signal
bald sind wir dumm wir nehmen jetzt
einfach von diesem tag hielt sich auch
schon ganz anders an alter sie
informiert so ein bisschen das dreieck
drumrum demand jetzt einfach so cook
packen das auch hier dran verstehen
ich mache mir das ein bisschen so zum
drei erkämpft so ein medikament
allmählich aber wir arbeiten ohne jobs
ist erstens hätte sich schon langsam aus
dem pizzastück deutlich gewannen bis
montag gesehen werden gucken die
schulter macht ein bisschen aus stoff
arbeiter mit sichern aber viermal besser
mal hauptsache die probieren es mit
flaschen mit stein und auszurollen
effekt wie flexibel aber gearbeitet
wenn ich für die katz ich würde sagen
freunde so verkehrt wie cd's nicht außer
man gibt man erkennt dass es ein
pizzastücke finde ich denke auch wenn
man das jetzt belegt damit dass man eine
ganz andere sagt hey leute ich glaube an
den teig jetzt so circa fertig also
wärst du das mal von oben sieht man dass
es ein pilz stück ist das ist das pc
pitstop eltern sehen vor allem auch das
größte pizza stück das größte wir machen
jetzt die tomaten scheint machst du sau
da darf natürlich das größte pizzastück
es oft die größte tomatensoße nicht die
meist aber die größte die viel star ist
ich heiße ich ohne grund
lokalpolitischer vorname den hintern
luca noch niemand gesehen so gleichmäßig
verteilt hast du es gelernt auf die
beiden köpfe und wieder bleibt offen
diesen drei meter dicken rändern oder
ich will es gar nicht wissen was
schmeckt echt ekelhaft denn das erste
mozzarella welchen baywa steht der
müller scharf und jahre auch schon das
zweite mutter welchen das heißt ich mein
letztes mal machen würde mir den fischen
die datennutzung wird nicht erfüllen
ich habe alles was gemacht und wir
wollen jetzt hier aus dem mozzarella
noch so ein smiley machen kochst du
eigentlich so lücke alle drei tage als
hoch kommen und dann packe ich da jetzt
noch habe ich den ton verstehen gelegt
habe ich den tod verständlich sich vor
hingelegt gelegt habe doch da ist der
thunfisch dankeschön dem jetzt vom
thunfisch einfach mal ein bisschen raus
und fakt dass hier vorne drauf
ich würde sagen die sind fertig oder
minuten alle wir müssen jetzt in den
qualitätstest machen bekennt snapshot
berding gesicht es mag leute das ist
jetzt quasi das pizzastück ist so lang
wie mein arm also meine hand passt man
nicht komplett rein ich nehme das jetzt
und praxis in den ofen ist mir schon
vorgenommen davon ist wahr geworden
wir packen jetzt ist größte pizza stück
in den backen
wir warten jetzt 12 13 minuten und dann
schauen wir mal was passiert denn das
ganze ist so abgelaufen und zwar derzeit
das theaterstück im ofen lag haben wir
für max kanal doch ein video aufgenommen
er den größten sneaker regel gemacht hat
ist das da hinten ist die sneakers
wiegel wenn ihr ihn aber sehen wollt
müsst ihr auf märkte video klicken ist
hinter beschreibung jedenfalls ist die
pizza derzeit angebrannt wir schauen uns
mal nur zweimal den ofen offenbar kalt
ich habe schon bessere pizzen gesehen
also weniger mal raus und das ist meine
damen und herren das größte pizzastück
der welt ohne mich dass ich so nicht die
mundwinkel nach unten getreten weil er
so freunde das jetzt jedes pizzastück
geworden es ist immer noch ein bisschen
warm aber ich werde es einfach mehr als
das geworden über so viel größer als
sein kopf probieren nun ein stück von
diesem pizzastück schmeckt aber nicht
klar
wir probieren frankreich bot ihrerseits
auch alles hat aber irgendwie was
sammler ist es so dass du so eine ganze
pizza in einem stück ist einfach das ist
megageil probieren dass sie zur ecke
roßkopf nächsten hab ich machen soll
wenn man diesen kompletten rand
abschneiden würde nur noch dass man mit
er hätte dann wäre ich sogar mehr leute
rathaus auf jeden fall mit diesem video
ich werde die pizza auf jeden fall doch
aufpassen denn ist das video gefallen
hat
dem fachmann fetten live da jetzt sind
ja auch die sieben tage vorbei wenig
mattes weil die bewertungen ausgemacht
habe also lass mir meinen dicken
leichter und bei 50.000 mache ich für
jeden von euch auch eine pizza wenn ihr
jetzt gerade noch dran sein schreibt mal
pizza und in die kommentare
und ich es jetzt auf